[Music]
and tested for Finland 21 years old
pretty strange for everyone yes
I don't so easily get into this habit of
following somebody's orders I think it
costs my personality you know I'm not
truly me trying to get these somebody
else to the face I'm gonna rely on to
the best names bye-bye
oh my god I thought that was just a cute
play or something you would dictate the
tempo of the game he's like a dog does
chasing a ball but you can't really see
the ball you're just trying to run after
the dollar who's running after the ball
Jerry say anything but vici gaming up
like it plugs into him I think he's one
of the only players that I thought our
players would understand like I let you
talk like he's the only guy that I
thought f4 you know when I realize that
I'm against em I just like I just close
the game and I just do another one
pause the tear trees TP coming from rtw
charity Oh Jack's the patient fader a
beautiful slap comes into play
Thompson is done but he is it's up when
the actor father
[Applause]
play
the save
Virgie
I think the next project is always most
difficult eventually I just have to keep
going this path it will come clear in my
mind what I really wanted
before he was a two-time TI winner
one of the most inventive position for
his dode has ever seen and a loveable
mastermind with some of the best here in
eSports Yesod jaracz wanaka was just
your average easygoing gamer growing up
in metropolitan finland come from
Helsinki I was born there I do my
occasional escapes to the nature and
build their nests in spite of this
carefree demeanor Gerak's was the kind
of guy who enjoyed adversity who enjoyed
challenging himself and ultimately
seeing what he was made of that's why he
loved video games because they allowed
him to test his mettle without fear of
consequence inanimate disease many
thought was it a blood pharmacy left an
angle have made a head there Opeth at
least that's it they like a lot of dota
greats Derek's got his start in Heroes
of Newerth
the fanatic fast-paced defense of the
ancients spin off and like a lot of
eSports hopefuls his journey towards
professional gaming was thwarted by a
stint of mandatory military service so
at that time when I was in high school I
also thought that uh I have to go for
military service
when you have is this trick routine it
is to be followed it isn't something you
have to kind of keep up with there's no
there's no such thing as what you want
foremost spending a little time in the
Navy would have simply been a learning
experience a way to top it out but for a
free spirit like Jer axe it was torture
I don't so easily get into this habit of
following somebody's orders I think it
kind of closes my personality you know
I'm not really me in that kind of
environment
he didn't care much for his studies
either despite showing a proficiency in
math school having grip chair acts the
way he thought it would he cared more
about the games he was mastering in a
spare time I didn't really know what I'm
gonna do with my life I went to this
schools and I would study like physics
and math but nothing felt as big in fact
it was his obsession with one game in
particular that changed everything I
described owed us something along the
lines of playing chess but also having a
team base hell-bent on entering DotA's
competitive scene Gerak's moved to
Stockholm in early 2013 in order to join
an up-and-coming roster known as the QP
ad red pandas untested for Finland 21
years old
pretty strange for everyone yes nobody
knows me but following a slew of awful
results the core members left the team
including jerax
deflated jerax returned to Finland and
spent the next year trying to make a
name for himself on teams such as for
tankers plus sea captain and team tinker
all to no avail
I believe this is the beginning at the
end double by becoming through the racks
we'll still go down by quite far as
running the interference on the front
line triple buy back now but boy will go
yow
yeah I do like two or three right takes
from anyone
Gigi gets called and for ASC or
eliminated well it's important to
understand that up until about 2014
jerax was a fairly uninspiring Romer he
was good but nothing to write home about
and then dota2 saw the addition of what
was easily the weirdest most skill
intensive support it had ever seen Earth
Spirit Earth Spirit is a strength here
whose variety of skill shot abilities
allow him to be one of the most robust
and unpredictable heroes in the game
Earth Spirit was unintuitive and for the
average player a nightmare to play you
needed a billion IQ to do well and he
required twice if not three times as
many inputs to do things that other
heroes could do in a single key press
and you get first grit it's like
apparently he has six stones they all
revolve around the three spells that you
have one like does this if you redo this
you do that if once slows kind of one
pulls down everything's like kind of
like Messi is is totally it's crazy
Messi as though the trade-off was that
in the right hands this hero could do
anything naturally for a zany
free-flowing thinker like Jax it was
love at first sight I personally think
I'm a little bit more individual player
than actually a team player this is kind
of funny for me to say I have this calm
side of me and then I have this
energetic like full accent yes in a bid
to make it to ti at all costs Jarek
started talking to MVP hot6 is Hien in
2015 and made the drastic decision to
relocate to the single-most esports
centric country in the world I joined
the team because I knew he was not my
coach I had out of this problem where I
didn't really feel like belonging in the
team and I was looking for team so Korea
kind of took me I it was like three days
basically go to Korea and
I had like maybe five days to tell I
travel so I needed to with my university
and stuff like this
it was very intense back then because I
didn't really know what I'm gonna do and
what's gonna happen by 2016
girag stock had risen and it became
clear that his stint the East had worked
in one respect he returned to Europe as
one of the hottest supports in the
region he then joined his first tier one
roster the kuroky led five John's who
are quickly signed by liquid so starting
on for two but the storm at Monsanto
just raining they learn mind control but
look at these three man checked with the
magnetized as well and now they're
coming in with the ultimate with the
exorcism two dead at the moment on the
side of Vega they're going to lose
pressure as well huge combo they're from
the boys on liquid within no time Jarek
shots at the top putting up top tier
result after top tier results but liquid
just couldn't close the racks are
falling even if they kill no-till once
they gotta do it again and he's not dead
yet
Jericho going on up to a mega kill the
bear about the trouble of the BKB but
they beat up butter they go sips at a
point defensively the bear will fall the
arrows legs Oh Jer doing a lake when
they can't withstand
punishment oh gee by the manila major
champions second time the first ever
team to repeat by the time that year's
international world's around liquid or
being hailed as potential favorites
desperate to shake his second-place
curse Jax entered his first TI full of
hopes expectations and well nerves 3.3
foot back but the racks and Foley but
she's gonna get the objective
[Applause]
liquid-liquid of going home
we never seen for them
following his disappointing turnout at
ti 6jx felt that he needed a change in a
somewhat surprising move
he left liquid in favor of a European
master who also imploded at TI the
difference was that this one had a track
record for doing what jerax couldn't
winning majors and here you folks oh gee
your manila major camp it's built on
optimism greatness and a whole lot of
friendship oh gee wouldn't just be
jaraxxus next home it would be his last
getting jarek's made sense the biggest
mistake of my life it was the best for
position during that time having Jack
strong was super hype he's incredibly
good at the game Jarek took two OG like
a fish to water
outside of the game he was as loyal and
loving as the brothers who'd adopted him
inside he was quirky unconventional and
talented he had a unique way of roaming
it was like he saw things that others
just didn't sure he would dictate the
tempo of the game he's like a dog does
chasing a ball but you can't really see
the boat you're just trying to run after
the dollar who's running after the ball
alongside fly no tail and they're
invaluable coach Seb jerax team old his
way to back-to-back major wins Luigi
your pasta made you
they had issue the DAC they have ova
condom to push through this
single-elimination dangerous bracket and
beat out a team that is look superb
throughout this entire tournament but a
sperm
[Applause]
[Music]
the hope is that with the help of Jer
axes calm creative play making OG would
finally hoist the aegis the year prior
they dominated everything outside of the
international only to crumble on the
game's biggest stage on day number 2 ti6
something that I would never imagine
myself with ti seven on the horizon
people figured that there was no way
these four-time major winners could bomb
out of TI again but they did Levin's
fishing he's got the refresher BKB
didn't get off the lasso very early but
now here ankles in no-till he's got
another lasso available control over the
top into the side
three dead put more blood started
boiling it don't tell snacks they keep
on going no my bets on three the end is
nigh GG LGD sway the peace they move on
is a bitter pill to swallow
poor time major champions but it's just
something about TI that OG just can't
seem to get it together
it was problems of like being too
emotional in the games we were kind of
like shattered I would say you can only
take so much right like every time you
go for TI and every time you lose every
punch feels different from there on out
it felt as if Oh G were coming apart at
the seams this time they didn't bounce
back and they failed to put up results
outside of TI to for all intents and
purposes
Oh G were dismissed as a sinking ship
over time because they won so much and
we're so dominant it's only natural that
watching OG flounder a little bit
definitely was enjoyable for some people
and yet through it all it felt as if
jarek's was the one thing about OG that
couldn't degrade or deteriorate it
wasn't just his jubilant personality
it was his remarkable level of play his
innate ability to understand DotA's
deepest intricacies both in and out of
the game
[Music]
okay oh my god I thought that was just a
cute play or something Oh G had become a
part of Jer axe and he a part of them
even as it looked like the ship was
starting to sink he remained loyal to
the brothers who'd adopted him as their
own unfortunately not everybody was a
stalwart when you lose a lot you also
lose trust things get hectic you can
have a conversation and then suddenly
it's an argument and suddenly the
argument makes this trust and then on a
dark and rainy day during ESL one
Birmingham following an especially rough
loss to fnatic
it happened and well we just got called
into a room and I learned that the two
players are leaving and one of them is
my best friend as for leaving short I
could understand that but fly leaving og
it's not just the captain
he owns part of the team his girlfriend
is the manager of the team it would tear
the team apart if he would leave three
months out of Ti it felt as if the heart
of og had been ripped in half
to be honest it felt as if jerax the
only truly top-tier player remaining on
that roster should take his wares
elsewhere not much was said I think max
three sentences were spoken in their
room then they left
you spent eight years together and now
it's over that was how that happened but
he didn't Jarek stayed to do the hardest
thing of all start over
there's a lot of things you need to
prepare for yourself for making it to TI
and then just making that sure that all
happens the preparation goes well that's
what I want to do and then make it
whatever happens and the rest as they
say is history
we've got six days with the best dota 2
teams in the world 25 million dollars in
total the top team taking away 11
million of that the largest eSport prize
pool in history maybe a team fight win
if they can jump forward and find the
abyss Alonso winters Kurt but it's not
gonna happen they have the role poured
on to - it's not bad but off on the side
Thompson with the BKB out punching
people down they find two kills that's
teach
ot on in the upper bracket
static with this victory moving into the
top six four oh geez
unbelievable conformance from a team
that feels like they just form showing
up sure on the main stage and taking
down BJ storm that's looked like one of
the best teams in the tournament looking
at oh gee and how they played today do
you think that momentum is gonna carry
on it's definitely possible but if the
next round is gonna be very very tough
for them
Oh G vs EG i love me some spicy stuff
and OG vs EG probably the spiciest match
of being a day with the players and i'm
sure there'll be perfect gentleman and
they'll be sportsmen likes as well
[Applause]
remember hitting my keyboard so hard
that the keys fell off one step closer
to the ages from open qualifiers to the
Grand Finals of the biggest stage in
dota og orchestrated what is arguably
the greatest cinderella story in the
history of eSports and at the centre of
all their confidence all of their
rallies all of their unthinkable
comebacks was their rock jaracz
dan stop play G writes the save your
Virgie probably the craziest table the
whole tournament that we've had so far
he was the source of some much-needed
pressure relief I'm trying to get these
somebody else to the face I know you
want to rely into the best memes puffle
bye-bye
but what a lot of people didn't realize
is that when it mattered most his team
could count on Jer ax to close the deal
echo echo
yeah it doesn't matter how you
reposition he seems like he also go
ahead it doesn't matter and that's
really doesn't matter grab a bus again
the game
[Music]
[Applause]
following their unimaginable triumph at
TI 800g began to play with
never-before-seen levels of confidence
and nonchalance of course Derrick said
pretty much always played that way but
without any notable wins after they
claimed the ages by the time TI 9 rolled
around OG were pretty much seen as a
write-off tremendous as the run at last
year's international had been it was
largely thought of as a fluke a
beautiful awesome divinely ordained
fluke but a fluke nonetheless well it
hasn't been that difficult for us so far
no day a way for them to also win TI 9
well i mean come on that would just be
impossible right oh my god I can't
believe this I got many Wasaga this game
for a Luigi
that's okay guys we had to go around
[Music]
[Applause]
Dondre against every expectation oh gee
emerged from the International 2019 as
the first group of players ever to amass
two TI titles
what's more they'd amassed them
consecutively making their
accomplishment doubly unprecedented they
weren't just great they were the greats
the undisputed goats and everyone knew
it
basically and your friends imagine
people that argued for years that jerax
was the best position for player in the
world but now it was pretty much
indisputable the reinforcements are here
the call has been made Fiji gaming could
have just kite out in phone'll slowly
tick away they're just making it to the
Pine Thursday please know Derek saves is
anything but vici gaming up
that's why it was especially
heartbreaking when in January of 2020
just when the jokes about OG winning ti
yet again were starting to come into
season
jerax announced his retirement from
professional dota there was quite
literally nothing in all of dota left
him to accomplish he done everything
he'd set out to do and he done it on his
terms this this fact that I achieved it
and then I was kind of left into
emptiness was something that cost a lot
of feelings I think over I was not the
easiest year for myself at least I think
coming from winning ti I think it can
heavily affect you how you look at
tournaments and people start looking
things differently for Gerak's winning
to TI's was a turning point as far as he
was concerned the time had come to stop
look around and say now what I have to
keep asking myself what do I really want
with life what is really that important
to go forward for it work for its kind
of finding this part that I kind of
lights up whatever I've given to dota
needless to say it was sad to see Jax go
but it became clear that it would be
wrong for the community who adored him
so dearly to hold it against him the
thing that made Jarek so endearing in
the first place was his freewheeling
nature his desire to go against the
grain I think the next project is always
the most difficult eventually I just
have to keep going his path
I'm clearing my mind that I really
wanted Gerak's is in every sense of the
word
both in game and out never to be tied
down the kind of person who doesn't
stick around long after he's mastered
something and master dota he did it
isn't clear what his future holds but
one thing is for sure as with everything
Jax has done
the beauty of it lies in the
unpredictability the deep
inextinguishable idiosyncrasy that makes
jer axe well jer axe thanks for watching
if you want more content like this hit
the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite-sized
videos you will find anywhere else hit
up our Instagram Twitter and Facebook
pages